que pensez vous situez vidéotron d'image
il y en a pas beaucoup vous savez qu'est
ce qu'on fait pour répondre aux demandes
cette partenaire de chambre a racheté la
roupie au japon pour arriver aussi
[Musique]
j'ai plein cabanis ouhlala c'est
toujours barré par cas pas d'âge pour
cela des gens qui trouve ça un peu
indécent qu'on n'aille pas occuper tout
ça met en valeur à 70 ans vous avez
encore envie de faire l'amour bien sûr
que ça dure
c'est malheureux et vous en pensez vous
madame
moi je suis d'accord c'est pas parce
qu'on vieillit qu'on applique désir
moi j'ai mis un bon casse-croûte toutes
les occasions je veux avoir moi je vais
vous faire si je mens un film porno j'ai
dit mon dieu mais c'est quand même se
régale la ville les gueulards réglages à
faire l'amour
faire durer jusqu'à marseille quelques
jours d'intenses et c'est toujours avec
une grande joie que l'on fait d'actes
sexuels comme en ont fait leur bail du
jeune homme sont quand même attentif aux
dames un peu âgées défense a exigé
qualité on paie plus cher mais ça dépend
du partenaire aussi comique nous y amène
ici et quelques efforts des chercheurs
marche pas où on va
m
[Musique]